chloe bleibt am monatsende kaum geld
übrig nach miete metro und
studiengebühren
regelmäßig kommt die junge frau daher in
dieses studentenzentrum in marseille ein
nebenraum dient als mini markt für
lebensmittel studierende mit geringem
einkommen zahlen hier nur zehn prozent
des preises
ich muss nachweisen dass sich knapp bei
kasse bin der studentenverein prüft dann
meine unterlagen und wenn man akzeptiert
wird darf man hier günstig einkaufen
die nachfrage ist groß als der laden
während des lockouts im frühjahr
schließen musste er hielt chloe von dem
verein jede woche ein lebensmittelpaket
15.000 wurden insgesamt an die studenten
verteilt viele haben uns gesagt dass sie
ohne unsere hilfe nicht genug zu essen
gehabt hätten
deshalb haben wir die körper so voll wie
möglich gemacht um allen gerecht zu
werden chloe bekam wie viele andere die
wirtschaftlichen corona folgen schon
früh zu spüren
überall im land wurden arbeitsverträge
nicht verlängert mussten menschen
schließen
zwar hat die regierung studenten in
finanzieller not eine hilfe von 200 euro
gezahlt doch das reichte in vielen
fällen nicht
ich suche einen nebenjob um ein
einkommen aufzubessern
seit der ausgangssperre gibt es viel
weniger jobs und sehr viel nachfrage für
wenige stellen auch denn ab ist oft hier
im zentrum zum lernen 70 prozent der
studenten gehen laut einer studie davon
aus dass sich ihr start ins berufsleben
deutlich verzögern wird der pandemie
fallen nicht nur jobs sondern auch
perspektiven zum opfer denn ab und ihre
kommilitonin unterstützen einander
versuchen das verpasste aufzuholen
der unterricht fand nicht so wie geplant
statt bei den online vorlesungen gab es
immer wieder probleme
jetzt beginnt schon das nächste semester
aber wir haben noch große lücken beim
stoff vom vergangenen samstag
und dann noch abstand halten maske
tragen denn ab belastet all das immer
mehr
wir jungen leute brauchen doch ein
sozialleben sind widmen ihr verrückt
zumal die lebensbedingungen nicht immer
einfach sind die marseille gehört zu den
größten uni städten frankreichs in der
küstenregion leben mehr als 95.000
studenten teuer und eng sind die zimmer
in den wohnheimen umso größer der
freiheitsdrang geschlossene bars können
sie nicht abhalten
es war schon kompliziert sich zu treffen
man will ja neben der uni nicht nur die
eigenen vier wände sehen wir treffen uns
jetzt öfter in den wohnungen dann in
kleineren runden aber wir finden immer
eine lösung uns zu sehen
und so trifft diese zweite corona welle
frankreich hart betroffen vor allem die
großen studentenstädte als zu fettig
steht die jugend in der kritik in paris
kamen in dieser altersgruppe zuletzt 800
infektionen auf 100000 einwohner als
super sprayer werden sie unter
generalverdacht gestellt ein vorwurf den
die studenten nicht so einfach
wegstecken erzählt die psychiaterin
domenico sprung die junge menschen in
der krise berät student sein heißt nicht
nur zu lernen sondern auch sich in einer
gemeinschaft von jungen menschen zu
engagieren
und natürlich all die feiern die auch
wichtig für die gruppen identität an die
hochschulen sind eine zeit in der ein
wichtiges kontaktnetz für die zukunft
geknüpft stattdessen schwindet die
lebensfreude einige ihrer patienten
leiden unter angstzuständen lang sind
inzwischen die wartelisten in den
beratungsstellen der unis auch weil sich
der unterricht seit beginn der pandemie
zunehmend ins virtuelle verlagert
vorlesungen seminare prüfungen am
bildschirm nicht alle können damit
umgehen was vor dem virus schützt kann
der seele schaden beim online unterricht
geht es ausschließlich um die
vermittlung von wissen
es ist sehr anstrengend für die
studenten humor austausch abschweifungen
alles unterhaltsame zurück hier gilt wie
in paris und anderen uni-städten die
höchste alarmstufe
[Musik]
im sommer haben viele franzosen im
eigenen land urlaub gemacht vor allem an
der küste und so wurde die stadt am
mittelmeer
erst zum party und jetzt zum corona
hotspot
das bekommt auch china zu spüren die
pharmazie studentin arbeitet neben der
uni ehrenamtlich in einem der
testzentren sie hat sich extra dafür
ausbilden lassen will sich in der krise
nützlich machen arena ärgert sich dass
studierende der zeit so oft am pranger
stehen
wir studenten werden oft stigmatisiert
das ist hart als student hat man einfach
viel kontakt man nimmt die metro zur uni
besucht vorlesungen und seminare
da ist doch normal dass man mit vielen
leuten zusammenkommt
und doch habe sich ihr alltag sehr
verändert erzählt alina die korona krise
hat viele pläne zunichte gemacht die
mobilität der studenten stark
eingeschränkt arena und ihre freunde
dachten ihnen stünde die welt offen doch
in der pandemie bestimmen unsicherheit
und angst vor der zukunft ihr leben und
das vieler junger leute